Okay so here are the two steps that we need to do on the top right hand corner.
Let's add them to our cord.
Now we're looking at, record sounds view controller and what I'm going to do,
is add AV audio recorder delegate to the class declaration.
There, step one is done.
For step two, I will scroll down to the record audio function.
Where we are initializing audio recorder.
And in here, I will say AudioRecorder.Delegate is equal to self.
So this means that audio recorders new delegate is self or
our class record sounds, view controller.
Now that I've finished both of these steps, I can start typing,
audio recorder did finish recording and as soon as I type that.
X code auto completes it for me.
Now this method will be invoked, when the audio has finished recording.
I will start writing code here soon.
But before we continue,
let me connect some of the new ideas we've seen recently.
One of the classes we've been using is called AVAudioRecorder.
Now, this class was written by Apple.
Among other things, it has a variable defined in it called delegate.
Now, the type of this variable, is not a string, not an integer.
But it's something called AVAudioRecorderDelegate.
What this is, is a simple list of methods.
One of which is called, audioRecroderDidFinishRecording.
So, in our class, which is RecodSoundsViewController.
When we see a line of code like this, what we are really saying,
is that we are becoming audioRecorder.delegate and
at that point, we can implement all of these methods.
By the way, don't take my word for any of this, you can go back to Xcode.
And use the Cmd key on your keyboard, to look through AVAudioRecorder and
confirm this relationship.
Once you've done that, I encourage you to come back to this quiz and
summarize everything you've learned about delegates in this box.